[Musique]
pour cela tous ces écoutes étaient mises
à jour sur la 1ère conférence donc moi
je restais un peu plus lent tout car en
guise d'introduction un peu plus
contextualiser les choses donc en
parlant brièvement du théâtre de niasse
je pense que ça vaut la peine quand même
de savoir qui est le théâtre les agents
pas exposer l'adn sont forcément jeter
des tonnes de chiffres comme ça sur les
dents dans ses conférences et simplement
dire on voit là un théâtre de guerre et
la première scène lui en termes de
fréquentation c'est 80000 spectateurs
par an ses 12000 disque d'airs ses 3000
abonnés ces cinquante spectacles
différents sur deux salles
ça représente environ 300
représentations par an donc voilà ça
situe déjà un petit peu gêné le niveau
avec un rayonnement local national
régional et international les ce n'est
pas que du théâtre et c'est ça aussi je
pense que ça vaut la peine d'expliquer
que c'est différent sorte de théâtre
certainement avec beaucoup de créations
pas beaucoup théâtre de répertoire dont
tout le répertoire revisité mais c'est
également de là dedans c'est ce que la
mairie technologie exposition d'art
contemporain festival de lecture ce qui
nous positionne vraiment sur l'échiquier
elles étaient des grands théâtres
européens à côté de théâtre comme la
chaux cunin berlin où le bo à paris par
exemple
donc voilà c'est des collaborations avec
de grandes maisons de culture à travers
l'europe mais également au travers à
travers le monde
on n'avait pas les plus loin par rapport
par rapport à l'institution que je
représente ce n'est pas du tout le but
du propos et voilà comme ça a été exposé
en guise d'introduction
alors pourquoi les entreprises
pourquoi
les entreprises mettent que j'aidais
interviennent dans dans la pérennité de
la culture bon je pense que j'ai pas de
convaincre sur la nécessité de la
culture qui est fédératrice des peuples
vecteur d'émotions en vecteur d'idées
mais aussi symbole de cohésion mais
aussi de diversité et ça je pense que
les régimes totalitaires avec l'arrêté
compris en détruisant tout ce qui est un
vestige du passé puisqu'il pt -2
archives témoins du passé en islande à
présent d'une pensée uniquement voilà
alors par rapport aux partants la
culture moi j'ai envie de dire que le
cadre actuel fait que dans un théâtre
si les gens dont je me suis dit ces
conditions aussi avec la dame d'une
abolition ici dans nos musées transports
en commun ce sont bien souvent des spl
mon île et les rapports de billetterie
comprend le peintre est ici à granby ce
conte théâtre on veut rendre la culture
accessible d'un pouce ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas les recettes de billetterie
qui vont nous aider à survivre
bien au contraire et donc c'est pour ça
que le port en public après la décision
de subsides et les entreprises dans tous
risques de m donc on serre
d autres sources de financement parade
aides qui sont la location de l'espace
je pensais que ça dessine en location
c'est pareil cas de viège
mais bon je pense que c'est pas ça qui
va assurer la pérennité sur le long
terme et donc le contexte économique
actuel est assez assez compliqué on
n'est pas encore dans le cadre d'un d'un
modèle anglo saxon on est dans un budget
de subsides lorsqu'on appelle toujours
le modèle d'un modèle français par la
position au nouvel an les actions ou des
ordres et ses actions sont vraiment
livrée à elle-même and the risk it
oreille et doivent d'en avoir plusieurs
personnes qui sont dédiés à la recherche
de deux suicides
donc voilà on ne concède quand même à
cette diminution des subsides au sein
des entreprises
l'entreprise culturelle et donc des
entreprises n'ont pas d'autre choix que
d'aller chercher d'autres sources de
financement eh bien je pense que vous
l'aurez compris les autres sources de
financement certains notables de cette
conférence c'est le préfet je pense que
beaucoup d'internautes ifs
d'où la nécessité d'impliquer les
entreprises dans
dans le financement de la culture
bien entendu c'est pas ça a été dit en
introduction 7 actuellement évident où
je rencontre dans mon métier le plus de
personnes qui sont déjà étonné de ma
fonction qui me disent maintenant
culture et économie c'est antinomique ça
ne peut pas cohabiter
je pense que j'en chie l'internation je
pense que c'est c'est le cas après bon
je sais pas dit comme ça ça s'avère
facile il faut expliquer aussi un peu
qu'elle était une infraction à ça je
voulais en discuter avec vous par après
mais voilà nous en ce qui nous concerne
dès l'ouverture du théâtre s'est posé
cette relation
par rapport au monde dans l'entreprise
tout simplement pourquoi parce qu'on
s'est retrouvé un très beau théâtre au
bout de 400 lots de travaux va sano
batmobile in qu'on avait ni chaises des
tables et donc là s'est posé la question
de savoir s'il allait faire
et alors enseignant apparaître une
entreprise qui s'appelle vitres et donc
on a cette première a promis un
partenariat avec avec notre mission
filtre à dilma n'y a pas de souci le
théâtre de liège va être un show room
est donc vite sera équipé l'entièreté du
théâtre avec son mobilier tables chaises
est à peu près dans tous les espaces aux
ricains mais également tous les espaces
du tertre
après cette correction s'est prolongée
notamment dans le cadre d'un festival
saguenay un pacte est un festival de la
nouvelle technologie est là aussi on
s'est dit bon quel est notre rapport par
rapport à ces entreprises qui sont les
grands noms jeu permet d'évoquer mais on
leur en nombre des entreprises
technologiques et par l'ars a continué
cette réflexion où ces 10 mai donc pas
aller plus loin on peut encore le plein
pour cette cette démarche de dead des
entreprises a vraiment les impliquer et
alors
l'idée était de mettre sur pied un club
en plein d'entreprises moi je viens de
parler autour d'eux parlait d'un club
d'entreprises
j'ai envie de mettre un cercle des
mécènes ou ce sont des entreprises qui
soutiennent des activités du théâtre de
liège alors ce n'est pas un sou pour le
voir comment est-ce qu'on sort une bête
et méchante ou des entreprises a
parcouru 50 argent tout simplement j'ai
dit le fonctionnement ce que va beaucoup
plus loin dans le sens où on a entendu
les membres se réunissent donc c'est
clair et net work in bon ça peut l'être
un peu à peu exclusif
j'ai envie de dire puisque l'on sait
désormais je vais dire le ticket
d'entrée est quand même assez assez
conséquent pour landreau crise
culturelle
mais l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir cet
apport financier qui est directement
injectés dans des projets donc c'est un
profit en ciel n'est pas un certain
acheter une voiture pour le terrain donc
les membres de ce feu ont l'opportunité
de décider
les spectacles les projets sur lesquels
le rapport financier va être va être
agitée donc c'est de la création c'est
de la diffusion et de la programmation
c'est également des parents des projets
pardon pédagogique avec des écoles nous
à nouveau ce n'est pas l'apport
financier au monde y tient on donne dix
mille euros une école c'est pas du tout
ça
l'idée c'est de travailler de manière
vraiment transversale avec les écoles et
allouer un budget a des épaules
nous on a un travail de terrain qui est
fait par des acteurs professionnels
auprès de du public scolaire sur les
grandes thématiques actuelles qui sont
par exemple la radicalisation qu'on a un
exemple avec une école la discrimination
positive on voit la menace et scénarisé
ce taux n'est hélas il ya vraiment un
travail de fond qui a été fait avec des
étudiants des premières à la paix tôt
sur la problématique de la
radicalisation de la problématique des
migrations également voilà ça c'est ça
l'idée de ce club vraiment de fédérer
fédérer les énergies
tout autour de projets de titan lien
avec avec des activités du théâtre et
des activités culturelles et on ce qui
est à remarquer c'est que ce pour garder
c'est un projet assez unique dans les
arts de la scène il existe un tout petit
peu d'ordre les arts plastiques et je
m'en sors willis à bruxelles et même les
autres maisons de théâtre en france
c'est quelque chose qui est encore assez
assez peu répandue et qui est plutôt
novateur vos cigares en belgique et même
par rapport à d'autres d'autres maisons
de
le culture française europe et la
congédie z à venir des entreprises
culturelles de bon ben je pense que
quand on porte on a mis notre mini a
annoncé qu'elle s'était attelé à les
recevoir les subsides bon je vais
peut-être entendu comme moi certains
terrains cédés dans je pense notamment à
un théâtre arlequin mais pas que le
magic land aussi qu'un fait une sortie
assez médiatique et donc s'excuser tout
à l'heure ce modèle de subsides est
amené à je ne pense pas à disparaître en
tout cas pas tout de suite mais comme je
disais c'est les subsides ont diminué
petit à petit et donc l'avenir des les
plus petites structures
on pense va passer inévitablement par
soit leur disparition ce que je me
souhaite pas parce que je trouve ça
dommage en termes de diversité
culturelle
ou alors j'ai parlé ce qui paraît que
micro au poing n'ont pas d'autre choix
que de se rassembler et de collaborer
ensemble au sein de collectifs ou
d'associations voilà ça c'est un peu le
contexte
d'où l'importance pour eux pour nous
comme vaut mieux dire comme les autres
acteurs de la culture de se dire
l'important c'est vraiment de
sensibiliser les entreprises sur la
culture et leur faire prendre conscience
de leur responsabilité sociétale
bon après comme je dis les synergies ne
doit pas forcément ses limites et un
apport celui-ci évoqué l'apport
financier donc pour des veaux delà en
étant beaucoup plus créatif et je pense
que
entre vous déjà entendu parler de
prométhéen et des cailloux c'est ça je
pense est un super exemple ou des
entreprises sont récompensés pour leur
mécénat donc à quoi je pense sadc nomme
pas forcément viser à l'implant financer
mais ça peut être également un apport en
compétences donc c'est un avocat qui va
se pencher sur les textes et les mots ça
peut être également des menuisiers qui
vont mettre la main à la pâte pour 7,1
création d'un spectacle ça peut être
également un apport en apport en nature
en matière en matières premières
donc là je pense que il faut sortir du
cadre habituel de ce qu'on peut parler
de sponsoring mécénat est vraiment
parler de mécénat de compétences mécénat
de l'esnam de convenir de l'apport de
deux savoir faire et donc l'idée - sa
demande de pouvoir fédérer les énergies
de part et d'autre entre les deux
entreprises est vraiment mettre en avant
ce partage de savoir faire et donner
naissance à un projet à un projet commun
après je sais que c'est pas comme ça te
dit comme ça ça a l'air toujours très
facile mais je pense que le projet en
créant l'association avec une entreprise
va loin beaucoup beaucoup plus de poids
c'est le cas par exemple je prends
l'exemple notre projet sur lequel on
travaille où on noie la côte est un
artiste français qui s'appelle eric
hanna bloodshy bien qu'a fait ça si l'on
compte trois
dumoulin qui a fait gaffe et s'assied et
on travaille sur ce projet entre une
entreprise qui s'appelle safran un gros
bosseur et à liège qui fabrique des
compresseurs de moteurs d'avions et
s'est mis 22 jan aps le cri anciennement
ses ennemis qui fabrique ici une
structure métallique en forme de signal
le projet certaines courteix que l'idée
c'est de reconstituer un vortex hebdo
concept de ce signal l'idée d'en faire
une attraction c'est une partie de
l'attraction fête foraine mais bon on
line et sans faire une attraction en
tout cas nous on fait il ya cette place
qui vaut pour emmener à l'intérieur de
ce cortex d'eau ont l'idée de l'entendre
c'est travailler avec avec un mec dans
un jeu de sons et lumières et bien
entendu l'idée ce n'est pas de se
limiter à se dire bon a fait
l'attraction pour le baril a une
visibilité derrière pour les entreprises
en explosant par exemple les transferts
que je trouve ça prend tout son sens et
le salon du bourget par exemple voilà je
pense qu'ici on peut encore vraiment
sortir du cadre l'ucav habituel dans la
relation de sponsoring mécénat
on se rapprocher qu'il ya beaucoup plus
de sens
donc voila moi en guise de conclusion
j'ai envie de dire que l'aurez compris
que mon propos c'est inévitablement à
l'avenir entreprises et entreprises
culturelles vont être amenés à se
rapprocher
sinon l'entreprise culturelle au risque
c'est notre soutien se rapprocher les
mondes de monde économique leur estime à
70 à prizren soit amenée à disparaître
comme sur les demandes pour les parcs
maintenant lui tout à fait faire ce
rapprochement dans la manière
intelligente dans la collision aussi
surtout dans la cohérence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]